at what point did you
did you kind of have an idea that you're
up to something big like when was it
when you said you know
i think this could really have some legs
and turn into a real business
so to be honest it happened quite
quickly
so we i i mentioned the body power expo
we i was at that expo and this is when
the business was very very small
and i had a it was like a
gut a proper proper innate gut feeling
that we had to be there the following
year bear in mind at this point we had
no product to be there i just thought we
have to be here
now when i think that was may 2011
we were walking around as customers and
i just thought right we've got to be
here i went straight to the the
organizers stand and i said
i want to stand here next year what does
it cost i think it was three thousand
pound for the entry level stem
and i just again more money than we'd
ever seen but i thought right fine
we've got 12 months to pay for it we'll
find out a way of doing it um so we
booked into that and over the year
that's where we had made a lot of these
clothes and we built up the brand
now about two or three months before
that event the people the youtubers that
we've been sending product to who had
over time become friends that we've been
chatting to over skype
we invited them to come to the event
with us so they were all buzzing some of
them were from the states and hadn't
been to the uk before some of them were
from the uk
um and we did this event and
i'm not saying it was a corporate event
because it wasn't but we were just like
listen
there's we're here we want to chat with
the community we would just love the
community more than anything anyway
and almost like by the way if you want
to buy some product and that's great but
after the show we're going to go to the
gym and we can all lift together and we
sort of started to started to build this
community
the show went really really well i was
really happy with how it went we sold
out of a lot of the stuff
but over that weekend because there was
only a small handful of us in the
business
we turned all the website off and we
thought right we'll kick it back off
monday when the event's finished
now what i didn't realize is we'd
stumbled upon i guess the sort of
marketing mix as you call it of today
so we did an in real life event where we
launched new products and no one could
get their hands on it
we had all these youtubers and what are
now called social media influencers
there that were posting on facebook and
youtube and so on and built up this huge
crazy demand and hype that everyone was
looking at
um and then like i said because we were
going and lifting with everyone after
the event
all of those guys were following us on
social and sort of falling in love with
the brand and the community that we were
all building together
now after the event i went home and i
was sat at my parents house one
evening and i just sort of turned the
website on thinking nothing would happen
post it on facebook just to let everyone
know that it's back and we're launching
the product that we'd sold at the event
now before the event for context we were
selling on average two to three hundred
pound a day worth of product
again very very proud of where we built
up to we were doing really well
the first half an hour after we turned
the website back on
we sold 30 000 pounds of product
sold out of everything and i was
literally because the stock was set to
infinite i was having to go through each
product and turn it off
um because we had to go and make the
product
and i'll never forget it right it was
about one o'clock in the morning the
website was turned off we had thirty
thousand pound worth of revenue more
revenue than
we'd ever thought was possible in a
thirty minute period
and it i was literally sat there on my
own i was thinking okay
now now we're on to something special
and that's when i left pizza hurt that's
when i left university and that's when
everything was just all focused on jim
shaw
wow thirty thousand dollars in first 30
minutes and you're used to doing 300
200 to 300 a day and that takes off to
30 000 you turn off all the products
okay
so when that happens by the way ben how
many shirts have you personally sewn if
you were to say i've sewn
that you know so many shirts how many
have you personally sewn
i could probably work it out
it would it would i would say i would
guess between 500 and a thousand
it wouldn't be massive amounts but at
the time it felt like a lot five hundred
two thousand and so
uh people still have them and then when
we go to events
prior to kobe people would come in some
of the original ones and because there
was always slight
um imperfections in the print or
something and i would sort of
instantly know and remember it would
come back to me so that's one of the
handmade products wow
i bet i i mean it's a form of art when
you're designing those because it's
it's limited edition it's it's not
necessarily something that's uh it's a
one-off because
it's being handmade okay so that 30 000
event takes place
in 30 minutes products done you turn
everything off what are you doing next
well this is where it became on what i
would call like a real business because
this is where we had to sort of hire
people we were starting to buy in stock
and take more and more risks
um we got our first sort of unit
small warehouse i think it was about 300
square feet
um this is where it became a real
business and this is where i think i
sort of really had to learn because up
until that point it was just
entrepreneurial it was like there was
there was no
responsibility for lack of a better term
it would just go where you want do what
you want and it's just grow grow grow
and just go off and enjoy yourself
now at this point we had to hire people
and responsibility was happening we were
taking on leases
so that was a real sort of learning
curve for me and like i said because i
dropped out of university and my
my job um it was literally a case of
i'm all in on this so 24 7 i was just
all on
all on jim shark and essentially getting
it to grow as quickly as possible and
i think what we did after that and this
is this is something that at the time
came very natural and it didn't feel
like a risk but looking back i felt it i
think it was a bit of a risk
that one event did well so then we were
like right let's sign up to every event
that we possibly can so we signed up to
body power in birmingham we signed up to
an event called fibo in germany um the
la fit expo in los angeles
um the arnold in columbus ohio
melbourne and we literally just flew
around the entire world
going to all these events we spent every
penny we had and just did event after
event after event whilst the guys were
working back home
uh in that new warehouse that we've got
to ship out the orders
how did that which one would out of all
the events you went to i mean you know
the
arnold expo quarter million people show
up was there one where you said that was
another one that was a big success
um to be honest they were all really
unique so
i'll always remember every single one of
them to be honest so columbus ohio was
crazy because i didn't realize
anywhere got that cold so english
winters aren't that cold
we went to columbus ohio and i think it
was december
it was freezing but it was incred the
thing that shocked me about that event
was the scale
it was i don't know if you've been it is
huge
and the actual event is massive and they
do so much right all the way from
bodybuilding
to there was sort of like people to talk
to around sort of joining the military i
think there was
um all these different sports even
having arnold schwarzenegger there was
just an amazing thing to see um whereas
the european expos tend to be quite
you have a bodybuilding expo and then
you have maybe a slightly different expo
for different
things so that was amazing but the thing
that really hit me
especially going to places like germany
and the states was
it almost hit you even harder doing it
in in the international stage because
you just assume that no one
has heard of the brand and it was on
that that was the moment when i'm
starting to realize that wow this social
media thing
this website online direct to consumer
e-commerce thing is
it's a global thing now whereas when
you're at home it just feels like a
little bit of a
you know a thing that happens around
where you are so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye